i met the vice president pepsi once uh
vice
chairman of pepsi and we became friends
he's a doctor and you know he
had some interesting conversations and i
said why why do you guys use high
fructose corn syrup he says the
government makes it too cheap for us not
to use it
wait let's talk about corn a little bit
because i always the high fructose corn
syrup one always strikes me as the
craziest thing that if you
buy a coca-cola in the united states yes
uh i believe it's the second ingredient
and you know it's water and then it's
high fructose corn syrup yes
if you buy a mexican coke in mexico or
that one that's been brought here
the second ingredient is sugar how did
we in america were so advanced
and yet we can't even do the sugar thing
well you know even though sugar that
ain't that great for you
i met the vice president of pepsi once
uh vice
chairman of pepsi and we became friends
he's a doctor and you know he
had some interesting conversations and i
said why why do you guys use high
fructose corn syrup he says the
government makes it too cheap for us not
to use it
there's there's all kinds of tariffs on
sugar to prevent importing sugar
to keep the prices you know uh higher
and and to actually help corn farmers
use their products for the
sugar which helps americans but it also
kills americans yeah geez yeah yeah
what a screwy one i mean it's just it is
great it is crew yeah yeah you go to a
store and you got to pay more for the
sugar one
because the prices are artificially low
right so
uh it's challenging and i think uh we we
kind of have to look at
how do we create uh things that aren't
you know overly
uh onerous for people but that
incentivize them to do the right thing
and disincentivize them to the wrong
thing
right i think that's what what what we
do through our tax code we can
incentivize our tax code
why do we for example pay allow the food
industry to take a 15 billion dollar tax
cut
or not pay taxes on marketing junk food
why do we do that i mean cigarettes
there's enormous taxes there's enormous
disincentives you can't advertise why do
we let them do that i mean
we can say free speech fine but why
should we let them have the benefit of
that right so what what model
is better for us so i see what you're
saying so okay we're exporting a lot of
this but where are the places that are
that have a model that maybe makes a
little more sense just well i mean
listen
europe is so far ahead of us there's no
gmo half the ingredients in our food
that we allow
they don't allow food additives colors
dyes
uh something like azodicarbonamide which
is a yoga mat material
that is used oh isn't that in the rib is
that the water it was in subway
yeah it was in subway buns it was in a
lot of it's a lot of the fast food buns
yeah and and and it's still allowed in
this country it's a
demon as a yoga teacher and a food guy
this must kill you that's right and
and you're in in singapore for example
uh which is a very you know
restrictive country if you use that as a
food manufacturer
in your product you get a 450 000
fine and 15 years in jail and we allow
it here
right products like bht and and
and are are preservatives that are not
allowed in europe there's a whole list
of these in my book
of why do we have them here and not
there uh
and and so we we have to look at how
different countries are addressing this
and europe
as collectively as focusing on
regenerative agriculture on changing
their system
chile is is a great example of a country
that has implemented a whole series of
food policies
that have had great impact in reducing
obesity and ill health
which are completely unpalatable in this
country so
the only way it got done was the vice
president of the senate
and the president of the country at the
same time
were doctors and they got this and
they're like we're going to fight the
food industry
so they they put in a ban on junk food
advertising to kids from six in the
morning to live at night
they banned all cartoon characters on
kids food so no more tony the tiger they
killed
toucan sam and tony the tiger slaughter
yeah they put
warning labels on the front of packaging
like cigarettes
for bad food they eliminated advertising
of
formula to kids they eliminated any junk
food in schools
and they put in 18 18 soda tax
and and they funded there's been funding
to
assess the impact of this 30 million
from bloomberg actually to fund what
this
actually is doing and they found
dramatic improvements and the most
dramatic benefit wasn't even from the
soda tax it was from the
ban on marketing and the warning labels
reduce consumption
four times more than soda taxes is the
increasing of taxes on these things is
that
just really a short-term stop though
because eventually if you get enough
people to stop then you don't have the
tax money anymore and then you might be
funding other things with the tax money
i don't i mean it's been a model that
you know it's very controversial but
uh larry summers and michael bloomberg
create a fiscal task force
around the world the financial finance
ministers to look at how do we use
financial policies to
change behavior right so you you tax the
things you don't want people to do
and you incentivize the things you want
people to do right so
so savings you don't tax uh you know and
maybe soda you should text right
and i think that it's been effective
across the world it's just a it's just a
challenging thing to do the data is
really clear that it works
cigarettes we do it on cigarettes and
we've done in berkeley we've done in
philadelphia we've done it in
many many cities but the problem is the
food industry fights back
so so in the last election 2016
four cities in california passes soda
tax there are six cities totally
uh in the country and and the food
industry freaked out so the big soda
companies then
created a strategy to prohibit future
taxes
so what they do is for example they went
in california
and they created a ballot measure that
would prohibit local taxes unless it was
a two-thirds majority
which would mean it would [ __ ] local
governments to fund schools
to fund police departments fire
departments and
and they didn't care about that but they
spent seven million dollars
funding this campaign it would have
passed because people don't like taxes
right five days before the election they
went to governor brown
who was also called governor moonbeam
probably the most liberal governor in
history
they said if you don't pass this
preemptive
law that prohibits future taxes on soda
and junk food
we're going to leave this ballot measure
in and you're going to be screwed
so he basically was bullied they made
him in quote an offer he couldn't refuse
like the mafia
and he had to pass this tax which now
prohibits future taxes
and they're doing this in state after
state after state so all this happens
behind the scenes yeah
all it can politics is messy yeah and so
so as as consumers we're sort of like
stuck with
uh you know this system that is
perpetuating
a disease-creating system and a
disease-creating economy
uh and it's it's it and it's threatening
our entire
way of life and people just don't get it
it's like if we don't fix this
you know we're all gonna be really sick
and fat and
get all these chronic illnesses which we
already are our economy is going to be
crippled by this i mean think about it
if one in two dollars of our entire
federal budget is for medicare
i mean like there's no money for
anything else right yeah all right so
we have sick people suddenly from all of
this or i guess not so suddenly it's
happened over generations
we've gotten an economy that the
incentives are completely out of whack
let's talk about that planet thing too
how is this affecting
the planet we've talked a little bit
about yeah so so so here we talked about
some of the environmental impacts but
what you know what people don't realize
is that
um the very way we grow food is
threatening our ability to grow food
because of its impact on our climate and
weather right
so so if you look at end to end our
entire food system
it's 50 of climate change or fossil
fuels is about a third
so it's worse than fossil fuels why
deforestation
you know we kill seven billion trees a
year the size of costa rica
soil erosion from our way of farming and
the tilling factory farming of animals
food waste transport refrigeration all
these things and then
you add them up and it's 50 the good
news is that
if that's true we can fix it and the u.n
said that if we took 2 million of the 5
million degraded hectares of land around
the world from over grazing and from
poor farm techniques and we converted to
regenerative agriculture which is a way
of farming that restores and builds soil
that conserves water that increases
biodiversity pollinators et cetera et
cetera produces better food more food
that's more profitable for the farmers
if we did that we could stop climate
change for 20 years
and it would cost 300 billion dollars
which is less
than medicare spends on diabetes every
year in america if you're looking for
more honest and thoughtful conversations
about
lifestyles instead of non-stop yelling
check out our lifestyle playlist and if
you want to watch
full interviews on a variety of topics
check out our full episode playlist
they're both right over here and to get
notified of all future videos be sure to
subscribe
and click the notification bell